[Music]
[Applause]
is the Hall of Famer Clippers consultant
and 14-time All-Star Jerry West back on
the program number two pick overall
how did you get the phone call to tell
you you'd been drafted by the Lakers do
you remember
I didn't get a phone call I was in
college
and somebody came back I I believe and
that's a long time ago Dan
um the um
someone from the PR department from the
West Virginia University came back and
told me I didn't even know until I get
the day after it happened
was there was there a um competition
with you and Oscar since Oscar was taken
number one overall
well I'd like to think there was when I
first started in the league he was so
much Advanced more more advanced than me
and I think that by playing in the
Olympic games together it probably
showed me that I had a way to go in
terms to maybe get to where I could be
considered uh maybe his equal or or even
as good as him but uh his his route
there was a lot a lot different
and um he played in you know in a from
Indianapolis he played there he had a
lot of great competition so
um I didn't see that kind of competition
uh certainly not in college
and uh he still one of the players that
most admire moves from my time during
the NBA
I want you to be the GM of the Angels
what would you do with shoheiotani if
you were running the angels of trying to
keep him or trade him at the trade
deadline
oh my goodness that's an incredible
question you know uh one of the things
Dan I pay attention to all sports and
every once in a while some of one of
these iconic players comes into
any sport and you're
actually enthralled by him with him he's
uh he's one of the most unique players
that I think I've ever seen in baseball
from this perspective uh
go out and pitch bat
and I wonder if he would just take one
side of the the uh the game and um
really concentrate on that what would he
really be but my goodness he is he's
just an amazing he's probably the most
um most interesting player in the
baseball for me and I'm not a huge
baseball fan until we get to World
Series time
but what do you do as a GM
can you go talk to him or his agent to
say help me understand here do you want
to stay what kind of money we're talking
about if not then I gotta I gotta trade
you
well I think that's a great question
again the last part of it which I was
going to answer
um he's such a draw Dan you can't
measure what he does to a for a team in
New York
you know people come to see the Yankees
I mean they're uh they're like the
Dodgers their name is going to be there
forever but with him my goodness I would
think his uh the way he attracts people
all kinds of people and the uh the
closeness that the fans feel to him he
is again he's one of those unique
players I would have a difficult time uh
letting him go I was very difficult time
and I would do anything in my power uh
to keep him simply because if you look
at Los Angeles and particularly New York
also the the diversity and the
population people from you know
everywhere uh he's the melting pots both
cities are for for people who have
immigrated this country and established
themselves
yeah absolutely yeah but if you know
that he wants to test the market
then he's going to put you in a really
delicate situation because you might end
up losing him and not have anything to
show for it
well you're that's the other side of the
equation Dan I think it's really
important in regards to what you're
doing when you run a team establish
close personal relationships with these
people make sure they know how much you
care about them and want them there
isn't something like a block there uh
he's he's Japanese at uh at heart
um and if you listen to him talk
he just you don't know what he you don't
know what he's even thinking sometimes
he just so he's so well coached in
everything he does but uh oh my gosh uh
that's that would be the first thing and
you need honesty into today difficult to
find in among agents and players I think
talking to Jerry West the Hall of Famer
uh what piece of advice would you give
Victor one by Yama after watching him
play
um just gained some weight and uh he is
um
he explains himself really well Dan he
is unbelievably polished I think after
the first game I saw him play in the
summer league I would say I went there
and I maybe because of all the hype I
was expecting to see a little bit more
he got he gets up with the writers
afterwards and how many times do you see
an athlete say you know I didn't play my
best game I think I'm going to get
better going forward mostly there's
um it's hard to get some honest answers
from players today because of the way
they're uh the way they're taught what
they see with other athletes conducting
themselves in front of a microphone but
he was got at me he said I'm going to
get better going forward
um
he's fun
um he got a smile on his face but the
way he will represent not only the Spurs
but the league is that to me is what's
going to make him really special beside
of his ability compare him at 19 with
Kobe
uh you know I'm not really supposed to
talk about other athletes but um
uh Kobe
Kobe was more advanced you know he
wasn't that height he wasn't his body
was bit bigger but they both bring a
different kind of excitement to the game
and I'm very hopeful that for the Spurs
and particularly for the league that he
will be one of those players that will
people want to come see play because of
the uniqueness of his talent and
anything that's good for basketball and
particularly the growth of the game I'm
all I'm all for it all right I don't
want you to get fined here but I saw
where Jake
James I'm gonna call Adam and tell him
yes yeah I'll call Adam and tell him
um James Harden says that he wants to go
to the Clippers
uh I'm not going to get into that one
Dan do not okay that that'll cost us if
if uh you talk about that the Xbox is in
line you know players say a lot of
things Dan but they really don't have
control over where they go uh how
important is summer league in your
opinion as a former GM
I would say that you'd have to go back
in time because we uh back in time there
was it first started here in Los Angeles
and one of the people that uh uh that
you
um doesn't get enough credit for running
this summer league Warren legary used to
be a former agent a great friend of mine
and uh he's done an incredible job it
started here in Los Angeles it went Long
Beach came back to LA and all of a
sudden here it is in in Vegas this is a
training ground for the NBA teams uh you
have all these young coaches today and
certainly we need we we're always
looking for new coaches who can come in
and reach a gap when
um when but one time coaches were
recycled so much Dan and I think after a
second time at least I would look at it
and say there's something wrong here
let's get some of these new Young
coaches a chance and there's some great
coaches in our league there's been great
coaches in the past and secondly it's a
training ground for the officials
um it's um it is it's just amazing how
how encompassing this is how it helps
other team how it helps the NBA last but
not least who would ever have thought
that we would have two sellouts in a big
building
uh to watch these kids play it is
popular you go to Vegas there's two uh
it's the ideal venue there's a gym where
the ladies play and a gym with a the big
bigger gym where the uh where the men
play and it's it's just amazing what
I've seen the league accomplished over
these terms of time but they don't
they're involved and it's also last but
not least of people who want to see
these young very hyped players they get
a chance to watch every one of their
games on TV no one would ever seen that
before and it's it's been a tremendous
it's been tremendous would the game be
better if we took out the three-point
line
well Dan I think in 1988 I'm gonna give
you a background I believe in 1988 the
Lakers won the championship
um that year
and I don't want to completely mess this
up but it's been a long time ago I think
we shot like 280 80 free throws and I
mean three-point shots in the course of
a game during the regular season a few
more in the playoffs but that team was
one of those unique teams
um that you don't see a symbol together
it's just hard to do it today with so
many so many different teams selecting
every every time in the draft and if you
can get a team that has really a unique
talent set there wouldn't be a lot it
wouldn't be the emphasis on the game uh
to shoot all of these threes I think
sometimes Dan it just gets to the point
where
I'm a you know I'm an elitist when it
comes to not elitist I'm a purist when
it comes to watching teams play I get
very excited to watch again these
rookies but it gets to the point where
passing which is one of the most
beautiful parts of basketball
it is it is not there anymore you can
get a three on one break the guy with a
ball he always goes to the basket and uh
I would rather see passing where Chris
passing and people want to see obviously
the dunks and the three-point shots
today which we have a lot of players
who's so athletic today that that that
do that but I enjoy the passing part of
it and if I'm watching a game and
particularly a uh a young player comes
in there and watch him throw these crisp
passes the coach is going to like that
but the game has changed and it will
change even more
um
I would say do you think we're ever
going to have a four-point shot who
knows yeah I would hope they would keep
where it is but uh back to the 288 free
throws a team will do that and uh I mean
three point shots the team will do that
maybe in six games now yeah so it's part
of the repertoire we're seeing people
that work on their shooting so much I
mean you see kids six eight six nine
seven feet shooting out there
I would prefer as I say just a little
bit more uh game where the coaches have
some control
to try to make their team more
competitive bad shots will cost you two
points at least on the other end today
who's in your starting five
you and then who's who else is in the
back court with you who's your big man
um in 1970 no right now if looking back
who would be your who's in the back
court with you oh my gosh Dan it would
be uh I wouldn't put my name in that era
uh I mean if I would love to play it in
this era with everything no but you got
your all-time team you you can take
whoever you want
well there's three players that would be
on there right away okay
one of them presently playing LeBron
James uh Kobe Bryant Michael Jordan I
would take those three players because
the uniqueness of the game today is
because it's almost a positionless
league
um those three players would fit in
incredibly beautifully uh you know all
of them could play probably three
positions and they have
and but the greatness of them as players
um
drives other people they're the people
that get it done when it counts most and
the rest of them I I could probably do
10 but I'm not going to go there well
who's your big man who's your big man
I'm not going there
um
there's so many of them I mean there's
so many of them my goodness you know you
go back to to when I played and again
Dan that's a long time ago you had uh
three players Chamberlain
um Russell Abdul-Jabbar
um
became Elijah one Bill Walton when he
wasn't hurt yeah
um and I I'm gonna miss someone and I do
apologize to the others I forgot but uh
didn't didn't suspect you're going to
ask ask me that question do you care
where you're ranked in basketball
history we we see like the top 10
and you know Steph Curry might
eventually be a top 10 player of all
time or Kevin Durant do you care
no then I I don't live in the past I've
I've been one of those people that
fortunate enough that
um I guess my ego is not big enough to
even care about that stuff I was just
happy that I had to put uh that I had a
chance to play When the league was
growing
uh when it was like a like a high school
game when you went in the gymnasium
something incredibly funny stories that
happened when he traveled man you
traveled and and coached with two two
seven Footers on our team
to even watch them to even watch them
try to sleep on the plane some guys can
just go right to sleep and one of my
Fondest Memories of one of those uh
Leroy L say Leroy Ellis he would get on
a plane he was asleep before the plane
went off
before it took off and he was asleep
when it landed but he always had this
gigantic blanket over his head I have no
idea how he ever did that how did Wilt
get on these planes
well as I say he you got on some way
somehow and uh uh players who are very
resilient there and there was no money
in the league and and you did really
play because you liked the competition
uh I think for all of us who played
during that era uh a lot of a lot of
players who and there's not a lot of
players still living from that era
um I knock on wood I'm still I'm still
standing so to speak
um
they a few of them uh very envious and
jealous of the uh salaries that players
are making today that has never bothered
me one bit I just feel fortunate that I
had a chance to play and um people
thought I was pretty good I guess when
you get named the one of the top 75
players yeah and it's just been a been
an unbelievable Journey for me to so to
speak to come from a real small place
play at West Virginia my home state
which I still love today and to play for
one team
and it wasn't a team of my choice I was
drafted and you had no rights to go
anywhere else other than wear that
uniform unless they wanted to get rid of
you there's no no equality for players
then that's for sure did I ever tell you
the story you guys came into Cincinnati
and the Royals beat you and I I got your
autograph and I got Bill Sharman I got
everybody but wilt
and Wilt sat in the first seat on the
bus
and after the game I saw him there he
didn't sign my autograph
I walked on the bus
I took one step up and I said you Mr
chairman would you sign my autograph and
he stood up and he said get the F off
the bus and that was my uh that was my
encounter with wilt
well that was probably not what you
expected I'm guessing
it was great it was great today today
not only the security guard
um uh but the um
Hampton to the bus is really protected
because usually under Arena oh yeah it
really changed when they had a chance to
say hello I wouldn't have gotten even
close but uh yeah I never never got
wilt's autograph there got everybody
else's your penmanship
beautiful
gorgeous when I was a kid in school I
used to be a I'd win the penmanship
Awards and uh
today I certainly wouldn't do it that's
for sure
um it's great to catch up with you hope
you're feeling well and uh thanks for
joining us as always
anytime Dan just don't ask those tough
questions I know I know be fine okay
okay
make sure you call the commissioner
thank you so much that's uh Jerry West
Hall of Famer